imagine if the pastors came forward okay
imagine if they said okay like because
that like they'll say they'll say you
can be saved right like the like the
hoes they'll be like hoes come to church
but I mean they don't say it like that's
where they basically say hoes come to
church because you can be forgiven for
everything imagine if they said men
don't accept that don't you like wait
for the next round of women leave them
in church yes what
I believe you know the Geeks no but I'm
no you're right you're right that's why
like that's why I've got there aren't a
lot of guys in general walk into any
church at 70 to 80 women but just
imagine if they flipped it and they said
don't accept that for like the same way
they'll tell men and I can't I'm trying
to articulate this right but the same
way they'll tell women like your husband
should be this this this he should be
equally yoked a man of God blah blah
blah blah blah but it's like they don't
say to the men don't date these ran
through girls don't do it you don't
deserve that you deserve better you
should date this this and this like it's
always what the women should expect from
a husband